foreign
[Music]
hi there YouTube it's me John Oliver
we're still on Hiatus right now but I
wanted to come back briefly to talk to
you about a couple of things and the
first is trash the thing that in his
lifetime Abraham Lincoln produced more
of than he did anything else and you
know what it's not just Lincoln is it
it's all of us call Mac McCarthy has
produced 12 novels and that's undeniably
a lot but it's not nearly as much as the
trash he's generated as a human being
Cormac McCarthy has pooped more than he
has written that's just a fact I don't
argue about it that's a fact it's not
just that cormax also sneezed into
tissues hasn't he's wiped his mouth with
napkins he's dumped out lasagna that he
couldn't finish but didn't feel like
saving and that's trash it's all trash
the most productive person on the
planet's creative output is dwarfed by
the amount of trash that they produce
and I'm including Shakespeare in this
too and Zendaya anyway
specifically I wanted to talk about
garbage cans in the small Swedish city
of Malmo it's basically the Ohio of
Sweden
is it it could be it's it's a it's a big
little city with an Ikea that kind of
feels like Ohio doesn't it you're not
going to check you're not going to
bother to figure out what I meant by
that honestly I barely know what I meant
by it just accept it pop tart to the
bagels of cake hair is the fingers of
the head Malmo is the Ohio of Sweden
things are whatever we say they are now
if you don't know anything about Malmo
don't be discouraged nobody does most
people are learning about it for the
first time with you right now the most
interesting thing about Malmo is that
it's home to Nina person the lead singer
of The Cardigans the Swedish band that
had an absolutely massive hit in the
mid-1990s with Lovefool you know the
song it goes like this
okay that's enough I I don't want that
song stuck in your head and I don't want
to pay for the rights to play it in that
exact order now the reason I want to
talk about Malmo is that it made the
news a few months ago for an unexpected
reason whilst Sweden Prides itself for
being clean and one of the countries
with the lowest levels of air pollution
Malmo is a Swedish coastal city trying
to encourage people to throw their
rubbish away using a dirty talking bin
here she's thanking someone
[Music]
yep
yep that's right
that's right in an effort to encourage
people to throw their Trash Away Malmo
programmed a few of his garbage cans to
moan sexily when utilized now a
reasonable question to this information
would be what happens when a child uses
the garbage can and a reasonable answer
to that is
shut up just shut up let's just enjoy
this not everything has to be quietly
bad these garbage cans moan and say
thank you after you put trash in them
and if you don't understand why that's
fun I'm honestly not interested in
knowing you you can you can choose to
spend your energy a finite resource by
the way complaining to me in the
comments below this video but please
know I will not read them and they will
not make an impact anyway the trash cans
don't just moan they also have things to
say
the programmed female voice makes
suggestive remarks asking for a little
more next time and come back soon to do
that again excellent
no notes from me do you know what some
notes if the objective is to get people
to throw away trash it is slightly
undermined by the fact that you don't
actually need to put any trash in them
to hear them moan you can just sort of
flick the outside part so no maybe
that's the point maybe Mama wanted to
remind people that penetration isn't
necessary and digital manipulation is a
completely acceptable path to pleasure I
don't know I'll never know I don't speak
Swedish and I'm simply not willing to
learn what I do know is that Malmo
system is clearly far better than our
approach to trash right here in New York
City which appears to be allow all
garbage to marinate in their own juices
loose in the sun until the world [ __ ]
explodes but
but to get back to my original point
sexy talking garbage cans exist in Malmo
and they're very very good and I know
what you're thinking you're looking at
how much of this video is still
remaining and you're wondering is all of
this going to be about the sexy talking
garbage cans well no no it isn't because
I now need to talk to you about a very
particular collection of garbage because
you may remember earlier this year we
acquired a dozen haunted creepy dolls
that were washing up on a beach in Texas
you may not remember why we did that
which is honestly fine I don't really
either sometimes we just do things to
dispose of them we thought we'd found
the dolls a home in Yara Australia a
place that we previously harassed for
unrelated reasons you may recall that we
offered them our giant alligator giving
the finger statue these frogs ten
thousand dollars to their local food
bank and a five thousand dollar donation
to the John Oliver koala chlamydia award
all all in exchange for this stupid
banana statue of theirs now they counted
our offer mixing the exchange of statues
but saying that they would name a
recycling plant after me for the
donation and guess what they actually
kept their word
hi everybody my name is Sophie Wade I'm
the mayor of the city of Yara we can now
declare the John Oliver recycling plant
open
yeah
yeah I did it get it and uh their
response there was the exact appropriate
level of enthusiasm for that
announcement now we asked them to run
these demon dolls through their
recycling machine but they pointed out
that they weren't the right kind of
plastic and might actually damage it and
at that point we were a little bit stuck
because these dolls need to be disposed
of we do not want them haunting our
office anymore Whispering the dates of
future plane crashes with their eyes and
we thought we might be in big trouble
until we remembered those Swedish
garbage cans because they seemed like
the perfect resting place for these
monsters so we started making plans to
dispose of the dolls in Malmo until we
were informed that the sexy moaning
garbage cans no longer moan when you
feed them trash as that was apparently
and this part is true only a summertime
event
yeah
yeah it really doesn't feel right does
it I don't want to get into a whole
thing about which season is the horniest
but it's obviously not summer is it it's
full it gets darker earlier and beds are
more inviting I shouldn't need to
explain it any more than I already have
but importantly
the garbage cans still have the ability
to speak if they were simply
reprogrammed and when we asked Malmo if
we could reprogram them to say whatever
we wanted they very unwisely said yes so
we sensed the dolls to Malmo to be
disposed of by literally the only person
that we knew lived there please enjoy
hi I'm Nina person I'm the lead singer
of The Cardigans and it's my honor to
dispose of these demon dolls for you
trash can
disturbing
bye
there are a few more
oh you want more okay
[Music]
see you in hell
man man
I'm just as fasting of an American's
trash
bye bye
off you go man here comes another one
[ __ ]
well here's the last one
no thank you
[Music]
well that's it please stop sending me
your garbage babies
we did it thank you so much Nina person
uh rest in peace demon dolls thank you
so much for watching this we will be
back in February goodbye
[Applause]